everyone said Judi Dench's in all of
these movies Janie are stars Maya why
Sapkowski boy that girl from Alice in
Wonderland whose name I'm having a hard
time pronouncing and I'm just waiting
for that commenter who's always tells me
that I pronounce things wrong I read
your comments buddy anyway we've seen
many adaptations of that book after a
while adaptations like Pride and
Prejudice and Jane Eyre can get like you
know what do these have to offer how
many times can here adapt the source
material before it gets old apparently
quite often Jane Eyre was orphaned at a
very young age and sent to live with her
aunt who was just not the greatest
person ever she didn't love her niece at
all and treated her terribly and sent
her to a very very very overly strict
school to the point of actual physical
abuse at this school she spent all of
her young life and teenagers at that
school being treated horribly and
learning how to be a respectful woman
and we get a lot of really good scenes
of a young Jane in this school
befriending the people trying to survive
in this atmosphere that is just horrific
ly strict I would die I would just my
word eventually she becomes the
governess of a household and she meets
Judi Dench who is the house maid there
and a dashing man who is the overseer of
the house and lots of drama and romance
and comedy ensues and Believe It or Not
suspense yeah this adaptation is
actually kind of creepy at times the
acting in this film is just fantastic
Judi Dench the main star Maya Wasik
house I'm sorry I'm being so
disrespectful but I have no idea what
her last name is all the main actors do
an excellent job it's very well written
it's directed very well and the reason
I'm saying that is because normally a
lot of these period piece films I just
don't have the pain
they're so so dull sometimes and this
one held my attention the old English
language people acting so so terribly
respectful all the time makes sometimes
for a boring film not here this this was
done really well one of the things that
doesn't always escape me about Old
English because it seems like they tried
to make really sappy romance scenes but
if they say it in Old English and and
film it well and they write it well it's
like we accept it but you know some of
this is really sappy I was just like
okay that is over the top romantic your
love is like the flower that blooms in
the mid morning Sun that's just an
example that wasn't actually in the film
I made that up myself yeah
the only really other problem I have of
the film is that it just was a little
bit slow at times but for the most part
this is a really solid adaptation great
performances I'm gonna give it Jane Eyre
three out of four stars if you're into
Perry piece films or you like older
romance films like that I would
definitely suggest seeing this film if
you like those kind of movies Maya Weiss
why am I trying her name again but she
did really good Jane Eyre stars Maya why
sakowski the girl that girl that girl
from Alice in Wonderland whose name of
having that girl from all the main
actors do an excellent job